la démission de la ministre jean
philippe hot lundi à ottawa peu après
celle de sa collègue et amie jodie web
monde nous inspirer quelques pistes de
réflexion pour cette journée
internationale de la femme nous avons
donc approcher une femme qui a exercé le
pouvoir politique est une autre une élue
qui ne l'a pas encore fait alors dans le
champ droit si je peux dire la
libéralisation la danse wars mozart est
dans le champ gauche jeu comme je puis
dire la solidaire catherine dorion
bonsoir madame dorion confort alors je
vous propose d'écouter à tous un extrait
de la conférence que john philpot a
prononcé ce matin man dans quatre jours
après sa démission
ça se passait à ottawa il était question
de l'équilibré hommes femmes justement
dans le monde et c'était évidemment la
première fois qu'elle parlait depuis sa
démission mais pas un mot à ce sujet
women want the simple things and peace
en partie nommée when équilibre entre
les hommes et les femmes peut provoquer
de tels bouleversements dans les milieux
des affaires de la politique
universitaire dans tous les autres
secteurs notamment parce que les femmes
en général ont des motivations
différentes de celles des hommes
c'est ce qui fait que nous exerçons
notre travail différemment alors je vais
commencer par aller chercher vos
réactions à ce que madame fait le pote
l'ex ministre présente conseil du trésor
a dit ce matin d'avoir avoue catherine
dorion est ce que les motivations pour
entrer en politique dont elle a sorti
une boutade d'une féministe américaine
qui dit que les hommes veulent le
pouvoir pour être quelque chose alors
que les femmes venues voir pour faire
quelque chose
qu'en pensez vous j'ai jamais trop
embarquer je respecte totalement c'est
vraiment des points de vue qui sont qui
ne s'annule pas l'un l'autre celui que
je vais avoir et celui jeunes entendent
mes jeux j'ai toujours vu comme le
féminin et le masculin faisant partie de
chaque personne ait trouvé dommage qu'on
dévalorise le féminin dans chaque
personne donc oui je pense que c'est
vrai qu'il ya certaines on peut
et en ce moment dire les femmes sont
plus si les hommes sont plus ça à cause
d'une certaine éducation de stéréotypes
de genre et de tout ça mais
dans la réalité énormément d'hommes qui
sont extrêmement sont dans lequel
justement qui veulent apporter quelque
chose qui va le faire du bien autour
d'eux il ya des femmes ambitieuses qui
veulent être quelque chose c'est bien
sûr je disais bien que c'était une
boutade mais cela dit à cause de notre
histoire à cause de la houle nous
enviait et de ce qu'on est encore
aujourd'hui
est ce que est ce que on peut entrer en
politique pour des motivations
proprement féminine madame me fout là
moi je pense pas moi je suis très très
content d'entendre catherine parce que
de la génération différente
je suis non seulement totalement
d'accord avec elle mais pour moi ça
mérite parce que je trouve que c'est
tout six clichés que de dire par exemple
toutes les phares sur les femmes blondes
ou à quoi que ce soit moi j'ai rencontré
des hommes en politique qui était pas là
pour être quelqu'un mais qui est l offre
vraiment pour changer des choses et j'ai
vu des femmes en politique qui ont pas
tout à fait réussi pic était aussi
désagréable que certains collègues
alors donc moment j'ai des vitesses la
catho à la catégorisation des jeunes
trouvent que les généralisations plus de
toute façon si on veut en politique et
résister autant c'est parce qu'on est
profondément profondément convaincu que
l'on peut en équipe
changer les choses justement parlant d'
équipe madame philpot en annonçant sa
démission a dit agir par respect pour
ses propres valeurs et des principes ans
issus de l'indépendance judiciaire
cela dit est ce que vous diriez que les
femmes sont plus susceptibles de quitter
un poste aussi prestigieux parce
qu'elles sont femmes au nom principe
justement mon swing de riom
non ça revient un peu c'est la même
question sans relâche ouais à chaque
année on se demande qu'est ce que les
femmes apportent que en quoi les femmes
sont différentes si une différence puis
c'est souvent les gens qui arrivent en
politique femmes comme hommes c'est déjà
un peu hors normes qui ont beaucoup de
de courage qui sont un peu originaux
quand même pour décider dans les
semaines sur la scène politique faut
être un peu étrange je pense en partage
avec dior comme dit ah ça fait que on
oui il ya des 13 plus féminin plus
masculin mais ils sont encore une fois
moi ce que j'aurais à dire c'est plus
ce que les stéréotypes de genre vont
dire que ce que doit être la femme c'est
là c'est là que c'est dommage c'est que
ces fameux justement se rendront
probablement même pas en politique parce
que celles qui sont qui sont à
l'intérieur d'elle-même très dominés par
ces stéréotypes l'oeil qui ont eu plus
de difficultés à s'en dégager à travers
leur vie réussiront pas à se faire assez
confiance pour aller occuper des postes
comme ce que j'occupe comme tu viendras
me prudent occupée cela dit il ce coup
là vous qui avez justement occupé un
poste de ministre
là on peut pas présumer que madame fait
le pote est parti aussi par solidarité
avec avec jodie foster est bonne on ne
s'est pas ça n'a pas été dit ça mais
cela dit est ce qu'il ya une solidarité
entre femmes
à une époque où au moins peut-être celle
ayant écouté d'abord ses motifs et les
directives pour les variations respecte
horizons moi je connais je vais vous
donner un exemple quand on dit elle ce
qui est des hommes qui ferait la même
chose je me souviens très bien joué dans
l'autre en politique on est en 90 91 et
ile seguin
on se rappelle était contre
l'implantation de la tvq
hello kitty et ministre des finances il
a quitté donc il y en a qui vont tout et
pour toutes sortes de raisons que ça
c'est un homme jean yves le plein d'eau
cela dit solidarité féminine à
sarre-union
je veux dire non seulement au conseil
des ministres mais la solidarité
féminine dans un record tient aussi au
caucus ça existe et moi j'ai vécu une
loi présentée par louise harel sur
l'équité salariale et toutes les femmes
des deux lots c'est parti québécois est
parti balle
on s'est mis ensemble et on se rappelle
que le conseil du patronat était venu
faire des représentations en disant que
c'était une catastrophe et que le québec
ça n'allait vraiment dans une débâcle
économique si ça arrivait et toutes les
femmes
on s'est dit de chacun de notre côté ça
va passer et sa pensée bon ça c'est la
valeur juste pour aborder un autre
aspect de la question bon snc lavalin
n'est pas la seule entreprise à faire du
lobbying on sait que c'est réglementé
ces permis
bing auprès des gouvernements cela dit
ce que ça soulève comme question c'est
celle de la proximité du pouvoir
politique avec celui de l'argent on peut
avoir l'impression que nos gouvernements
sont plus sensibles aux arguments des
grandes entreprises dont on sait
qu'elles sont encore dominée largement
par des hommes c'est de moins en moins
vrai mais c'est encore le cas
casse des arguments de groupes qui
défendent des intérêts plus
communautaire plus familiaux plus
sociaux catherine dorion là dessus bah
oui c'est vrai on le sait c'est drôle
c'est tension parle beaucoup de laïcité
dans l'actualité pts et il ya eu une
époque où l'église était vraiment très
piètre du pouvoir politique qui dormait
un peu ensemble dans le même lit pour
nos fêtes la laïcité pour séparer ces
deux pouvoirs la bleue c'est comme s'il
y avait un autre pouvoir qui couchait
finalement avec méthode qui était tout
le temps là puis on s'en rend pas compte
qu'on parle pas de séparation des
pouvoirs la disparation de du pouvoir de
l'argent
kiwi c'est vrai est dominé par un monde
d'hommes mais pas seulement avec l'état
qui lui c'est donc on vois pas ça comme
une nécessité comme on l'a vu un autre
époque entre l'église et l'état de
séparer ses pouvoirs le pourtant c'est
un enjeu qui c'est de ça dont on devrait
parler aujourd'hui c'est ça si on a une
laïcité qui devrait être dans les
journaux télé tous les jours ça serait
celle là je pense que les mécanismes
qu'on s'est donné actuellement
veut veut pas fait en sorte qu' il y a
aussi des ce que j'appelle mots des
mécanismes de prudence avant les gens
peuvent faire du lobbying
le financement des partis politiques
c'était beaucoup plus large et beaucoup
plus ouvert aujourd'hui bayeux le
registre des lobbyistes
il y a aussi les nouvelles règles de
financement des partis politiques
bon ça c'est pour vraiment contrôler les
flux ans cela dit ce que l'on veut ce
que l'on ne veut pas non plus ce soit
des politiciens qui sont dans leur bulle
ils sont pas capables de parler à
personne qui se veut pas les ministres
est ce que l accueil des groupes
communautaires à ce que je pensais les
groupes qui défendent le logement social
qui défendent les droits est présidée
il était très présent il avait une
oreille ou su aussi aussi attentive que
les grandes maisons
les uns ou les autres savent se faire
entendre
nous arrivons à faire entendre de façon
différente mais ils savent se faire
entendre
mais là c'est sûr que à ottawa qu'à moi
j'étais l'appelaient les règles se sont
se sont aussi raffermi c'est que à
tahoua qu'un joueur j'étais là c'était
contre au lit mais beaucoup moins
qu'aujourd'hui est ce que j'ai dit que
c'est parfait non mais moi l'erreur
puisque même pas se poser d'en parler
mais je vais vous dire
l'erreur dans toute l'histoire de la
vallée c'est beaucoup plus la
transparence beaucoup plus la
transparence que le fait que la
virulence et des présents non que je
donne mon sang c'est qu'un moment de
nîmes
je pense que la question de transparence
aussi c'est un point extrêmement
important dans les dossiers politiques
et catherine dorion catherine dorion je
devrais avoir besoin que vous allez
accepter de partager avec nous comment
vous êtes senti vous quand vous êtes
rentré l'assemblée nationale
ce que vous avez des réflexions en tant
que femme seriez prête à partager non
oui oui j'en ai c'est en fait moi je
trouve quand on parle beaucoup de gens
parlent de féministes du plafond de
verre de 2 pourquoi les femmes sont pas
dans des postes de pouvoir puis ça bon
on règle la chose de plus en plus mais
aujourd'hui je pense ce sur quoi il faut
se pencher c'est la raison pour laquelle
les femmes ont eu plus de difficultés à
monter dans l'échelle sociale et audio
systémique le sait c'est une cas
arrivent l'adolescence les jeunes filles
les enfants qui deviennent des
adolescentes se rendent compte que si
elle va être une femme pour correspondre
à l'image de faire mon modèle de femme
qui leur est présenté plusieurs milliers
de fois par jour sur des images en leur
écran sur les panneaux dans les films
c'est toujours le même corps de femme
c'est l'image le poids de l'image le
poids de l'apparence l'habillement le
corps tout ça devient en plus laissé ses
modèles de son photoshopée c'est
inaccessible inatteignable pour une
jeune fille d'atteindre sa les
psychiatres et les chambres pour
l'anorexie son plein c'est des filles on
ça joue sur l'estiment des feuilles ça
joue sur ce qu'on pense de nous mêmes on
se fait à croire qu'il faut être belle
avant les quoi que ce soit d'autre qui
font que notre apparence correspondent
mais moi je m'en rappelle même juste la
dernière fois que je suis venu à cette
même
on l'a en tant que députée élue avec
quand même une forte majorité dans mon
compte et je me faisais déjà parents
monsieur ex politicien si mes vêtements
à la télévision était correcte ou
incorrecte savez si je me disais si on
en est là
j'ai quand même que je dirigeais j'ai
réussi à tenir je suis pas certaine
qu'ils vous parlait en tant que femme
quand il faisait un commentaire sur
votre tenue vestimentaire
mais alors pourquoi c'est moi qui ai
subi toute cette avalanche médiatique
alors que soldats ce qui a valu à nous
n'a pas eue avec ses souliers beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins élevé gees des
souliers y avait pas mieux son franc
parler il ya tout ça alors oui lisant le
dernier aura qu on aurait pu penser mais
moi je moi je vais vous dire une chose
catherine en réseau mais encore
aujourd'hui là tout le focus sur le
corps on aurait pensé qu'on aurait
tourné la page mais là quand on regarde
la sexualisation sexuelle à son global
quand on regarde cela je voulais vous
dire tant le 8 mars aujourd'hui
catherine tu es d'accord avec moi celle
là on l'a pas encore gagné voilà je vous
remercie tout les deux d'avoir accepté
de faire cet exercice de réflexion
aujourd'hui sur notre condition de femme
s'il y en a une encore à venir
voilà merci merci au revoir